whether working with
ken or joe gee or not
try to uh realize it's not
a it's not a game
it's not a superman or a super woman act
it's uh you trying to improve your
aikido
improve your body the economies of your
body
moving the hip all the these these are
about uh
but it's about movement
floating with the feet
the point of impact can be when the foot
and the strike settled
it has the whole weight of your body
then arriving
at the stride
huh
whether going straight or turning to a
different angle
if the hips are controlling the legs
then hapogiri is made
all right
hey
[Music]
okay so work with your footwork
the suburbs first the birdie
the foot the same time as the parallel
cup
second to bury
same time lance's parallel cut
the back foot becomes the front foot
shift your weight
shift your weight it doesn't always
it doesn't always go land on the ground
the foot
sometimes it stays floating while the
upper body's doing some action
the head it's the leg is hanging off the
hip
sometimes they'll just tap the ground
there you go
that's the same first the berry
seconds of berry
that's the birdie
you won't see this in basics
see how boring this is now
see how choppy it's made it look
it's all disjointed everything's working
not as one but in
its pieces you'll see a lot of aikido
if you look hard enough on youtube how
it's all disjointed it has to be in
harmony
so
this has all been done on an incline
very steep incline in my garden
if you do hypogeary you'll get tests
but if you work from the hips you won't
feel the incline
it'll just fit because your your foot is
being carried by your hips
and your hips is not feeling the incline
it's just placing the foot down
where it needs to be placed okay you
more likely to see far more things that
i'm explaining
but that's what training is all about
it's using your eyes your judgment
pick out what you like about each
teacher use it
just because teachers are young and
dynamic doesn't mean say they actually
know what they're doing or what they're
striving for
and they know in their head these are
the things that i've been
taught i'm passing them